[MUSIC PLAYING - "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: Well, up 'til now, I
suppose, we've been learning
about a lot of techniques for
organizing big programs,
symbolic manipulation a bit,
some of the technology that
you use for establishing
languages, one in terms of
another, which is used for
organizing very large
programs. In fact, the nicest
programs I know look more like
a pile of languages than like
a decomposition of a problem
into parts.
Well, I suppose at this point,
there are still, however, a
few mysteries about how this
sort of stuff works.
And so what we'd like to do now
is diverge from the plan
of telling you how to organize
big programs, and rather tell
you something about the
mechanisms by which these
things can be made to work.
The main reason for this is
demystification, if you will,
that we have a lot of mysteries
left, like exactly
how it is the case that a
program is controlled, how a
computer knows what the next
thing to do is, or
something like that.
And what I'd like to do now is
make that clear to you, that
even if you've never played
with a physical computer
before, the mechanism is really
very simple, and that
you can understand it completely
with no trouble.
So I'd like to start by
imagining that we--
well, the way we're going to do
this, by the way, is we're
going to take some very simple
Lisp programs, very simple
Lisp programs, and transform
them into hardware.
I'm not going to worry about
some intermediate step of
going through some existing
computer machine language and
then showing you how that
computer works, because that's
not as illuminating.
So what I'm really going to
show you is how a piece of
machinery can be built to do a
job that you have written down
as a program.
That program is, in fact, a
description of a machine.
We're going to start with a very
simple program, proceed
to show you some simple
mechanisms, proceed to a few
more complicated programs, and
then later show you a not very
complicated program, how the
evaluator transforms into a
piece of hardware.
And of course at that point,
you have made the universal
transition and can execute any
program imaginable with a
piece of well-defined
hardware.
Well, let's start up now, give
you a real concrete feeling
for this sort of thing.
Let's start with a very
simple program.
Here's Euclid's algorithm.
It's actually a little
bit more modern
than Euclid's algorithm.
Euclid's algorithm for computing
the greatest common
divisor of two numbers was
invented 350 BC, I think.
It's the oldest known
algorithm.
But here we're going to talk
about GCD of A and B, the
Greatest Common Divisor or two
numbers, A and B. And the
algorithm is extremely simple.
If B is 0, then the result is
going to be A. Otherwise, the
result is the GCD of B and the
remainder when A is divided by
B.
So this we have here is a very
simple iterative process.
This a simple recursive
procedure, recursively defined
procedure, recursive definition,
which yields an
iterative process.
And the way it works is that
every step, it determines
whether B was zero.
And if B is 0, we got the answer
in A. Otherwise, we
make another step where A is
the old B, and B is the
remainder of the old A divided
by the old B. Very simple.
Now this, I've already told you
some of the mechanism by
just saying it that way.
I set it in time.
I said there are certain steps,
and that, in fact, one
of the things you can see here
is that one of the reasons why
this is iterative is nothing is
needed of the last step to
get the answer.
All of the information that's
needed to run this algorithm
is in A and B. It has two
well-defined state variables.
So I'm going to define a machine
for you that can
compute you GCDs.
Now let's see.
Every computer that's ever
been made that's a
single-process computer, as
opposed to a multiprocessor of
some sort, is made according
to the same plan.
The plan is the computer has two
parts, a part called the
datapaths, and a part called
the controller.
The datapaths correspond to a
calculator that you might
have. It contains certain
registers that remember
things, and you've all
used calculators.
It has some buttons on
it and some lights.
And so by pushing the various
buttons, you can cause
operations to happen inside
there among the registers, and
some of the results
to be displayed.
That's completely mechanical.
You could imagine that box has
no intelligence in it.
Now it might be very impressive
that it can produce
the sine of a number, but that
at least is apparently
possibly mechanical.
At least, I could open that
up in the same way I'm
about to open GCD.
So this may have a whole
computer inside of it, but
that's not interesting.
Addition is certainly simple.
That can be done without
any further mechanism.
Now also, if we were to look
at the other half, the
controller, that's a part
that's dumb, too.
It pushes the buttons.
It pushes them according to the
sequence, which is written
down on a piece of paper,
and observes the lights.
And every so often, it comes to
a place in a sequence that
says, if light A is on,
do this sequence.
Otherwise, do that sequence.
And thereby, there's no
complexity there either.
Well, let's just draw that and
see what we feel about that.
So for computing GCDs, what I
want you to think about is
that there are these
registers.
A register is a place where I
store a number, in this case.
And this one's called a.
And then there's another
one for storing b.
Now we have to see what things
we can do with these
registers, and they're not
entirely obvious what you can
do with them.
Well, we have to see
what things we
need to do with them.
We're looking at the problem
we're trying to solve.
One of the important things
for designing a computer,
which I think most designers
don't do, is you study the
problem you want to solve and
then use what you learn from
studying the problem you want
to solve to put in the
mechanisms needed to solve
it in the computer you're
building, no more no less.
Now it may be that the problem
you're trying to solve is
everybody's problem, in which
case you have to build in a
universal interpreter
of some language.
But you shouldn't put any more
in than required to build the
universal interpreter
of some language.
We'll worry about that
in a second.
OK, going back to
here, let's see.
What do we have to
be able to do?
Well, somehow, we have to be
able to get B into A. We have
to be able to get the old value
of B into the value of
A. So we have to have some path
by which stuff can flow,
whatever this information
is, from b to a.
I'm going to draw that with by
an arrow saying that it is
possible to move the contents
of b into a, replacing the
value of a.
And there's a little button
here which you push which
allows that to happen.
That's what the little
x is here.
Now it's also the case that I
have to be able to compute the
remainder of a and b.
Now that may be a complicated
mess.
On the other hand, I'm going
to make it a small box.
If we have to, we may open up
that box and look inside and
see what it is.
So here, I'm going to have a
little box, which I'm going to
draw this way, which we'll
call the remainder.
And it's going to take in a.
That's going to take in b.
And it's going to put out
something, the remainder of a
divided by b.
Another thing we have to see
here is that we have to be
able to test whether
b is equal to 0.
Well, that means somebody's
got to be looking at--
a thing that's looking
at the value of b.
I have a light bulb here which
lights up if b equals 0.
That's its job.
And finally, I suppose, because
of the fact that we
want the new value of a to be
the old value of b, and
simultaneously the new value of
b to be something I've done
with a, and if I plan to make
my machine such that
everything happens one at a
time, one motion at a time,
and I can't put two numbers in
a register, then I have to
have another place to put one
while I'm interchanging.
OK?
I can't interchange the two
things in my hands, unless I
either put two in one hand and
then pull it back the other
way, or unless I put one down,
pick it up, and put the other
one, like that, unless I'm a
juggler, which I'm not, as you
can see, in which case I have a
possibility of timing errors.
In fact, much of the type of
computer design people do
involves timing errors, of some
potential timing errors,
which I don't much like.
So for that reason, I have to
have a place to put the second
one of them down.
So I have a place called t,
which is a register just for
temporary, t, with
a button on it.
And then I'll take the result of
that, since I have to take
that and put into b, over here,
we'll take the result of
that and go like this,
and a button here.
So that's the datapaths
of a GCD machine.
Now what's the controller?
Controller's a very
simple thing, too.
The machine has a state.
The way I like to visualize that
is that I've got a maze.
And the maze has a
bunch of places
connected by directed arrows.
And what I have is a marble,
which represents the state of
the controller.
The marble rolls around
in the maze.
Of course, this analogy breaks
down for energy reasons.
I sometimes have to pump the
marble up to the top, because
it's going to otherwise be a
perpetual motion machine.
But not worrying about
that, this is
not a physical analogy.
This marble rolls around.
And every time it rolls around
certain bumpers, like in a
pinball machine, it pushes
one of these buttons.
And every so often, it comes
to a place, which is a
division, where it has
to make a choice.
And there's a flap, which
is controlled by this.
So that's a really mechanical
way of thinking about it.
Of course, controllers these
days, are not built that way
in real computers.
They're built with
a little bit of
ROM and a state register.
But there was a time, like the
DEC PDP-6, where that's how
you built the controller
of a machine.
There was a bit that ran around
the delay line, and it
triggered things
as it went by.
And it would come back
to the beginning and
get fed round again.
And of course, there were all
sorts of great bugs you could
have like two bits going
around, two marbles.
And then the machine has
lost its marbles.
That happens, too.
Oh, well.
So anyway, for this machine,
what I have
to do is the following.
I'm going to start
my maze here.
And the first thing I've got
to do, in a notation which
many of you are familiar with,
is b equal to zero, a test.
And there's a possibility,
either yes, in
which case I'm done.
Otherwise, if no, then
I'm going have to
roll over some bumpers.
I'm going to do it in
the following order.
I want to do this interchange
game.
Now first, since I need both a
and b, but then the first--
and this is not necessary--
I want to collect this.
This is the thing that's
going to go into b.
So I'm going to say, take this,
which depends upon both
a and b, and put the remainder
into here.
So I'm going to push this button
first. Then, I'm going
to transfer b to a, push that
button, and then I transfer
the temporary into b,
push that button.
So a very sequential machine,
it's very inefficient.
But that's fine right now.
We're going to name the buttons,
t gets remainder.
a gets b.
And b gets t.
And then I'm going to go around
here and it's to go
back to start.
And if you look, what
are we seeing here?
We're seeing the various--
what I really have is some sort
of mechanical connection,
where t gets r controls
this thing.
And I have here that a gets b
controls this fellow over
here, and this fellow
over here.
Boy, that's absolutely
pessimal,
the inverse of optimal.
Every line heads across every
other line the way I drew it.
I suppose this goes
here, b gets t.
Now I'd like to run
this machine.
But before I run the machine,
I want to write down a
description of this controller,
just so you can
see that these things, of
course, as usual, can be
written down in some nice
language, so that we don't
have to always draw these
diagrams. One of the problems
with diagrams is that they
take up a lot of space.
And for a machine this small,
it takes two blackboards.
For a machine that's the
evaluator machine, I have
trouble putting it into
this room, even though
it isn't very big.
So I'm going to make a little
language for this that's just
a description of that,
saying define a
machine we'll call GCD.
Of course, once we have
something like this, we have a
simulator for it.
And the reason why we want to
build a language in this form,
is because all of a sudden
we can manipulate these
expressions that I'm
writing down.
And then of course I can write
things that can algebraically
manipulate these things,
simulate them, all that sort
of things that I might want to
do, perhaps transform them as
a layout, who knows.
Once I have a nice
representation of registers,
it has certain registers, which
we can call A, B, and T.
And there's a controller.
Actually, a better language,
which would be more explicit,
would be one which named
every button also and
said what it did.
Like, this button causes the
contents of T to go to the
contents of B. Well I don't want
to do that, because it's
actually harder to read
to do that, and it
takes up more space.
So I'm going to have that in
the instructions written in
the controller.
It's going to be implicit
what the operations are.
They can be deduced by reading
these and collecting together
all the different things
that can be done.
Well, let's just look at
what these things are.
There's a little loop that we
go around which says branch,
this is the representation of
the little flap that decides
which way you go here, if 0
fetch of B, the contents of B,
and if the contents of
B is 0, then go to a
place called done.
Now, one thing you're seeing
here, this looks very much
like a traditional computer
language.
And what you're seeing here
is things like labels that
represent places in a sequence
written down as a sequence.
The reason why they're needed
is because over here, I've
written something with loops.
But if I'm writing English text,
or something like that,
it's hard to refer to a place.
I don't have arrows.
Arrows are represented by giving
names to the places
where the arrows terminate, and
then referring to them by
those names.
Now this is just an encoding.
There's nothing magical about
things like that.
Next thing we're going to do is
we're going to say, how do
we do T gets R?
Oh, that's easy enough,
assign.
We assign to T the remainder.
Assign is the name
of the button.
That's the button-pusher.
Assign to T the remainder, and
here's the representation of
the operation, when we divide
the fetch of A by the fetch of
B.
And we're also going to assign
to A the fetch of B, assign to
B the result of getting the
contents of T. And now I have
to refer to the beginning
here.
I see, why don't I call that
loop like I have here?
So that's that reference
to that arrow.
And when we're done,
we're done.
We go to here, which is
the end of the thing.
So here's just a written
representation of this
fragment of machinery that
we've drawn here.
Now the next thing I'd like
to do is run this.
I want us to feel it running.
Never done this before,
you got to do it once.
So let's take a particular
problem.
Suppose we want to compute
the GCD of a equals 30
and b equals 42.
I have no idea what
that is right now.
But a 30 and b is 42.
So that's how I start
this thing up.
Well, what's the first
thing I do?
I say is B equal to 0, no.
Then assign to T the remainder
of the fetch of A and the
fetch of B. Well the remainder
of 30 when divided by
42 is itself 30.
Push that button.
Now the marble has
rolled to here.
A gets B. That pushes
this button.
So 42 moves into here.
B gets C. Push that button.
The 30 goes here.
Let met just interchange them.
Now let's see, go back
to the beginning.
B 0, no.
T gets the remainder.
I suppose the remainder when
dividing 42 by 30 is 12.
I push that one.
Next thing I do is allow the
30 to go to here, push this
one, allow the 12
to go to here.
Go around this thing.
Is that done?
No.
How about--
so now I have to find out the
remainder of 30 divided by 12.
And I believe that's 6.
So 6 goes here on this
button push.
Then the next thing I push
is this one, which the
12 goes into here.
Then I push this button.
The 6 gets into here.
Is 6 equal to 0?
No.
OK.
So then at that point, the next
thing to do is divide it.
Ooh, this has got a
remainder of 0.
Looks like we're almost done.
Move the 6 over here next.
0 over here.
Is the answer 0?
Yes.
B is 0, therefore the
answer is in A.
The answer is 6.
And indeed that's right, because
if we look at the
original problem, what we have
is 30 is 2 times 3 times 5,
and 42 is 2 times 3 times 7.
So the greatest common divisor
is 2 times 3, which is 6.
Now normally, we write one other
little line here, just
to make it a little bit clearer,
which is that we
leave in a connection saying
that this light is the guy
that that flap looks at.
Of course, any real machine
has a lot more complicated
things in it than what
I've just shown you.
Let's look for a second at
the first still store.
Wow.
Well you see, for example, one
thing we might want to do is
worry about the operations
that are of IO form.
And we may have to collect
something from the outside.
So a state machine that we might
have, the controller may
have to, for example, get a
value from something and put
register a to load it up.
I have to master load up
register b with another value.
And then later, when I'm done,
I might want to print the
answer out.
And of course, that might be
either simple or complicated.
I'm writing, assuming print
is very simple, and
read is very simple.
But in fact, in the real
world, those are very
complicated operations, usually
much, much larger and
more complicated than the thing
you're doing as your
problem you're trying
to solve.
On the other hand, I can
remember a time when, I
remember using IBM 7090 computer
of sorts, where
things like read and write of
a single object, a single
number, a number, is a primitive
operation of the IO
controller.
OK?
And so we have that kind
of thing in there.
And in such a machine, well,
what are we really doing?
We're just saying that there's
a source over here called
"read," which is an operation
which always has a value.
We have to think about this as
always having a value which
can be gated into either
register a or b.
And print is some sort of thing
which when you gate it
appropriately, when you push the
button on it, will cause a
print of the value that's
currently in register a.
Nothing very exciting.
So that's one sort of thing you
might want to have. But
these are also other
things that are
a little bit worrisome.
Like I've used here some
complicated mechanisms.
What you see here
is remainder.
What is that?
That may not be so obvious
how to compute.
It may be something which when
you open it up, you get a
whole machine.
OK?
In fact, that's true.
For example, if I write down the
program for remainder, the
simplest program for it is
by repeated subtraction.
Because of course, division
can be done by repeated
subtraction of numbers,
of integers.
So the remainder of N divided by
D is nothing more than if N
is less than D, then the result
is N. Otherwise, it's
the remainder when we subtract
D from N with respect to D,
when divided by D. Gee,
this looks just
like the GCD program.
Of course, it's not a very nice
way to do remainders.
You'd really want to use
something like binary notation
and shift and things like that
in a practical computer.
But the point of that is that
if I open this thing up, I
might find inside of
it a computer.
Oh, we know how to do that.
We just made one.
And it could be another
thing just like this.
On the other hand, we might want
to make a more efficient
or better-structured machine,
or maybe make use of some of
the registers more than once,
or some horrible mess like
that that hardware designers
like to do, and
for very good reasons.
So for example, here's a machine
that you see, which
you're not supposed to
be able to read.
It's a little bit complicated.
But what it is is the
integration of the remainder
into the GCD machine.
And it takes, in fact,
no more registers.
There are three registers
in the datapaths.
OK?
But now there's a subtractor.
There are two things
that are tested.
Is b equal to 0, or
is t less than b?
And then the controller, which
you see over here, is not much
more complicated.
But it has two loops in it, one
of which is the main one
for doing the GCD, and one of
which is the subtraction loop
for doing the remainder
sub-operation.
And there are ways, of course,
of, if you think about it,
taking the remainder program.
If I take remainder, as you see
over there, as a lambda
expression, substitute it in for
remainder over here in the
GCD program, then do some
simplification by substituting
a and b for remainder
in there, then I
can unwind this loop.
And I can get this piece of
machinery by basically, a
little bit of algebraic
simplification on the lambda
expressions.
So I suppose you've seen
your first very
simple machines now.
Are there any questions?
Good.
This looks easy, doesn't it?
Thank you.
I suppose, take a break.
[MUSIC PLAYING - "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: Well, let's see.
Now you know how to make an
iterative procedure, or a
procedure that yields
an iterative
process, turn into a machine.
I suppose the next thing we
want to do is worry about
things that reveal recursive
processes.
So let's play with a simple
factorial procedure.
We define factorial of N to be
if n is 1, the result is 1,
using 1 right now to decrease
the amount of work I have to
do to simulate it, else it's
times N factorial N minus 1.
And what's different with this
program, as you know, is that
after I've computed factorial
of N minus 1 here, I have to
do something to the result.
I have to multiply it by N.
So the only way I can visualize
what this machine is
doing, because of the fact--
think of it this way, that I
have a machine out here which
somehow needs a factorial
machine in order to compute
its answer.
But this machine, the outer
machine, has to exist before
and after the factorial machine,
which is inside.
Whereas in the iterative case,
the outer machine doesn't need
to exist after the inner machine
is running, because
you never need to go
back to the outer
machine to do anything.
So here we have a problem where
we have a machine which
has the same machine
inside of it, an
infinitely large machine.
And it's got other things
inside of it, like a
multiplier, which takes some
inputs, and there's a minus 1
box, and things like that.
You can imagine that's
what it looks like.
But the important thing is that
here I have something
that happens before and after,
in the outer machine, the
execution of the
inner machine.
So this machine has
to have a life.
It has to exist on both times
sides of this machine.
So somehow, I have to have a
place to store the things that
this thing needs to run.
Infinite objects don't exist
in the real world.
What we have to do is arrange
an illusion that we have an
infinite object, we
have an infinite
amount of hardware somewhere.
Now of course, illusion's
all that really matters.
If we can arrange that every
time you look at some infinite
object, the part of it that
you look at is there, then
it's as infinite as
you need it to be.
And of course, one of the things
we might want to do,
just look at this thing over
here, is the organization that
we've had so far involves having
a part of the machine,
which is the controller, which
sits right over here, which is
perfectly finite and
very simple.
We have some datapaths,
which consist of
registers and operators.
And what I propose to do here is
decompose the machine into
two parts, such that there is a
part which is fundamentally
finite, and some part where a
certain amount of infinite
stuff can be kept.
On the other hand this is very
simple and really isn't
infinite, but it's
just very large.
But it's so simple that it could
be cheaply reproduced in
such large amounts, we call it
memory, that we can make a
structure called a stack out of
it which will allow us to,
in fact, simulate the existence
of an infinite
machine which is made
out of a recursive
nest of many machines.
And the way it's going to work
is that we're going to store
in this place called the stack
the information required after
the inner machine runs to resume
the operation of the
outer machine.
So it will remember the
important things about the
life of the outer machine that
will be needed for this
computation.
Since, of course, these machines
are nested in a
recursive manner, then in fact
the stack will only be
accessed in a manner which is
the last thing that goes in is
the first thing that
comes out.
So we'll only need to access
some little part
of this stack memory.
OK, well, let's do it.
I'm going to build you a
datapath now, and I'm going to
write the controller.
And then we're going
to execute this to
see how you do it.
So the factorial machine
isn't so bad.
It's going to have a register
called the value, where the
answer is going to be stored,
and a registered called N,
which is where the number I'm
taking factorial will be
stored, factorial of.
And it will be necessary in some
instances to connect VAL
to N.
In fact, one nice case of this
is if I just said over here,
N, because that would be
right for N equal 1N.
And I could just move
the answer over
there if that's important.
I'm not worried about
that right now.
And there are things I have
to be able to do.
Like I have to be able to, as
we see here, multiply N by
something in VAL, because
VAL is the result
of computing factorial.
And I have to put the result
back into VAL.
So here we can see that the
result of computing a
factorial is N times the result
of computing a factorial.
VAL will be the representation
of the answer
of the inner factorial.
And so I'm going to have to have
a multiplier here, which
is going to sample the value of
N and the value of VAL and
put the result back into
VAL like that.
I'm also going to have to be
able to see if N is 1.
So I need a light bulb.
And I suppose the other thing
I'm going to need to have is a
way of decrementing N. So I'm
going to have a decrementer,
which takes N and is going to
put back the result into N.
That's pretty much what
I need in my machine.
Now, there's a little
bit else I need.
It's a little bit more
complicated, because I'm also
going to need a way to store, to
save away, the things that
are going to be needed for
resuming the computation of a
factorial after I've done
a sub-factorial.
What's that?
One thing I need is N.
So I'm going to build here
a thing called a stack.
The stack is a bunch of stuff
that I'm going to write in
sequentially.
I don't how long it is.
The longer it is, the better
my illusion of infinity.
And I'm going to have to have a
way of getting stuff out of
N and into the stack
and vice versa.
So I'm going to need a
connection like this, which is
two-way, whereby I can save
the value of N and then
restore it some other time
through that connection.
This is the stack.
I also need a way of remembering
where I was in the
computation of factorial
in the outer program.
Now in the case of
this machine, it
isn't very much a problem.
Factorial always returns, has to
go back to the place where
we multiply by N, except for the
last time, when it has to
return to whatever needs
the factorial or
go to done or stop.
However, in general, I'm going
to have to remember where I
have been, because I might have
computed factorial from
somewhere else.
I have to go back to that place
and continue there.
So I'm going to have to have
some way of taking the place
where the marble is in the
finite state controller, the
state of the controller,
and storing that in
the stack as well.
And I'm going to have to have
ways of restoring that back to
the state of the-- the marble.
So I have to have something that
moves the marble to the
right place.
Well, we're going to have a
place which is the marble now.
And it's called the continue
register, called continue,
which is the place to
put the marble next
time I go to continue.
That's what that's for.
And so there's got to be some
path from that into the
controller.
I also have to have some way of
saving that on the stack.
And I have to have some way
of setting that up to have
various constants, a certain
fixed number of constants.
And that's very easy
to arrange.
So let's have some
constants here.
We'll call this one
after-fact.
And that's a constant which
we'll get into the continue
register, and also another
one called fact-done.
So this is the machine
I want to build.
That's its datapaths, at least.
And it mixes a little
with the controller here,
because of the fact that I
have to remember where
I was and restore
myself to that place.
But let's write the program
now which represents the
controller.
I'm not going to write the
define machine thing and the
register list, because that's
not very interesting.
I'm just going to write down the
sequence of instructions
that constitute the
controller.
So we have assign, to set
up, continue to done.
We have a loop which says branch
if equal 1 fetch N, if
N is 1, then go to the base
step of the induction, the
simple case.
Otherwise, I have to remember
the things that are necessary
to perform a sub-factorial.
I'm going to go over here,
and I have to perform a
sub-factorial.
So I have to remember what's
needed after I will
be done with that.
See, I'm about to do
something terrible.
I'm about to change the value of
N. But this guy has to know
the old value of N. But
in order to make the
sub-factorial work, I have to
change the value of N. So I
have to remember
the old value.
And I also have to remember
where I've been.
So I save up continue.
And this is an instruction
that says, put
something in the stack.
Save the contents of the
continuation register, which
in this case is done, because
later I'm going to change
that, too, because I
need to go back to
after-fact, as well.
We'll see that.
We save N, because I'm going
to need that for later.
Assign to N the decrement of
fetch N. Assign continue,
we're going to look at this now,
to after, we'll call it.
That's a good name for this, a
little bit easier and shorter,
and fits in here.
Now look what I'm doing here.
I'm saying, if the answer
is 1, I'm done.
I'm going to have to just
get the answer.
Otherwise, I'm going to save the
continuation, save N, make
N one less than N, remember
I'm going to come back to
someplace else, and
go back and start
doing another factorial.
However, I've got a different
machine [? in me ?] now.
N is 1, and continue
is something else.
N is N minus 1.
Now after I'm done with
that, I can go there.
I will restore the old value of
N, which is the opposite of
this save over here.
I will restore the
continuation.
I will then go to here.
I will assign to the VAL
register the product
of N and fetch VAL.
VAL fetch product assign.
And then I will be done.
I will have my answer to the
sub-factorial in VAL.
At that point, I'm going to
return by going to the place
where the continuation
is pointing.
That says, go to
fetch continue.
And then I have finally
a base step, which is
the immediate answer.
Assign to VAL fetch N, and
go to fetch continue.
And then I'm done.
Now let's see how this executes
on a very simple
case, because then we'll see
the use of this stack to do
the job we need.
This is statically what it's
doing, but we have look
dynamically at this.
So let's see.
First thing we do is
continue gets done.
The way that happened
is I pushed this.
Let's call that done
the way I have it.
I push that button.
Done goes into there.
Now I also have to set
this thing up to
have an initial value.
Let's consider a factorial
of three, a simple case.
And we're going to start
out with our stack
growing over here.
Stacks have their own little
internal state saying where
they are, where the next place
I'm going to write is.
So now we say, is N 1?
The answer is no.
So now I'm going to save
continue, bang.
Now that done goes in here.
And this moves to here, the next
place I'm going to write.
Save N 3.
OK?
Assign to N the decrement
of N. That means
I've pushed this button.
This becomes 2.
Assign to continue aft.
So I've pushed that button.
Aft goes in here.
OK, now go to loop, bang,
so up to here.
Is N 1?
No.
So I have to save continue.
What's continue?
Continue is aft.
Push this button.
So this moves to here.
I have to save N.
N is over here.
I got to 2.
Push that button.
So a 2 gets written there.
And then this thing
moves down here.
OK, save N. Assign N to
the decrement of N.
This becomes a 1.
Assign continue to aft.
A-F-T gets written
there again.
Go to loop.
Is N equal to 1?
Oh, yes, the answer is 1.
OK, go to base step.
Assign to VAL fetch of N. Bang,
1 gets put in there.
Go to fetch continue.
So we look in continue.
Basically, I'm pushing a button
over here that goes to
the controller.
The continue becomes aft, and
all of a sudden, the program's
running here.
I now have to restore the outer
version of factorial.
So we go here.
We say, restore N. So restore
N means take the contents
that's here.
Push this button, and it goes
into here, 2, and the
pointer moves up.
Restore continue, pretty easy.
Go push this button.
And then aft gets written
in here again.
That means this thing
moves up.
I've gotten rid of something
else on my stack.
Right, then I go to here, which
says, assign to VAL the
product of N an VAL.
So I push this button
over here, bang.
2 times 1 gives me a 2,
get written there.
Go to fetch continue.
Continue is aft.
I go to aft.
Aft says restore N. Do your
restore N, means I take the
value over here, which is 3,
push this up to here, and move
it into here, N. Now it's
pushing that button.
The next thing I do is
restore continue.
Continue is now going
to become done.
So this moves up here when
I push this button.
Done may or may be there
anymore, I'm not interested,
but it certainly is here.
Next thing I do is assign to VAL
the product of the fetch
of N and the fetch of VAL.
That's pushing this button
over here, bang.
2 times 3 is 6.
So I get a 6 over here.
And go to fetch continue,
whoops, I go to
done, and I'm done.
And my answer is 6, as you can
see in the VAL register.
And in fact, the stack
is in the state it
originally was in.
Now there's a bit of discipline
in using these
things like stacks that we
have to be careful of.
And we'll see that in
the next segment.
But first I want to ask
if there are any
questions for this.
Are there any questions?
Yes, Ron.
AUDIENCE: What happens when you
roll off the end of the
stack with--
PROFESSOR: What do you
mean, roll off of?
AUDIENCE: Well, the
largest number--
a larger starting point of N
requires more memory, correct?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yes.
Well, I need to have a
long enough stack.
You say, what if I violate
my illusion?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Well, then the
magic doesn't work.
The truth of the matter is that
every machine is finite.
And for a procedure like this,
there's a limit to the number
of sub-factorials
I could have.
Remember when we were doing the
y-operator a while ago, we
pointed out that there was a
sequence of exponentiation
procedures, each of which was
a little better than the
previous one.
Well, we're now seeing
how we implement that
mathematical idea.
The limiting process is only
so good as as far as
you take the limit.
If you think about it,
what am I using here?
I'm using about two pieces of
memory for every recursion of
this process.
If we try to compute factorial
of 10,000, that's
not a lot of memory.
On the other hand, it's
an awful big number.
So the question is, is that a
valuable thing in this case.
But it really turns out not to
be a terrible limit, because
memory is el cheapo, and people
are pretty expensive.
OK, thank you, let's
take a break.
[MUSIC PLAYING - "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: Well, let's see.
What I've shown you now is how
to do a simple iterative
process and a simple
recursive process.
I just want to summarize the
design of simple machines for
specific applications by showing
you a little bit more
complicated design, that of
a thing that does doubly
recursive Fibonacci, because
it will indicate to us, and
we'll understand, a bit about
the conventions required for
making stacks operate
correctly.
So let's see.
I'm just going to write down,
first of all, the program I'm
going to translate.
I need a Fibonacci procedure,
it's very simple, which says,
if N is less than 2, the result
is N, otherwise it's
the sum of Fib of N minus
1 and Fib of N minus 2.
That's the plan I have here.
And we're just going
to write down the
controller for such a machine.
We're going to assume that there
are registers, N, which
holds the number we're taking
Fibonacci of, VAL, which is
where the answer is going to get
put, and continue, which
is the thing that's linked to
the controller, like before.
But I'm not going to draw
another physical datapath,
because it's pretty much
the same as the
last one you've seen.
And of course, one of the most
amazing things about
computation is that after a
while, you build up a little
more features and a few more
features, and all of the
sudden, you've got everything
you need.
So it's remarkable that it just
gets there so fast. I
don't need much more to make
a universal computer.
But in any case, let's look
at the controller for the
Fibonacci thing.
First thing I want to do is
start the thing up by assign
to continue a place called done,
called Fib-done here.
So that means that somewhere
over here, I'm going to have a
label, Fib-done, which is the
place where I go when I want
the machine to stop.
That's what that is.
And I'm going to
make up a loop.
It's a place I'm going to go
to in order to start up
computing a Fib.
Whatever is in N at this point,
Fibonacci will be
computed of, and we will return
to the place specified
by continue.
So what you're going to see
here at this place, what I
want here is the contract that
says, I'm going to write this
with a comment syntax, the
contract is N contains arg,
the argument.
Continue is the recipient.
And that's where it is.
At this point, if I ever go to
this place, I'm expecting this
to be true, the argument for
computing the Fibonacci.
Now the next thing I want
to do is to branch.
And if N is less than 2--
by the way, I'm using what
looks like Lisp syntax.
This is not Lisp.
This does not run.
What I'm writing here does not
run as a simple Lisp program.
This is a representation
of another language.
The reason I'm using the syntax
of parentheses and so
on is because I tend to use
a Lisp system to write an
interpreter for this which
allows me to simulate the
machine I'm trying to build.
I don't want to confuse
this to think that
this is Lisp code.
It's just I'm using a lot
of the pieces of Lisp.
I'm embedding a language in
Lisp, using Lisp as pieces to
make my process of making
my simulator easy.
So I'm inheriting from Lisp
all of its properties.
Fetch of N 2, I want
to go to a place
called immediate answer.
It's the base step.
Now, that's somewhere over
here, just above done.
And we'll see it later.
Now, in the general case, which
is the part I'm going to
write down now, let's
just do it.
Well, first of all, I'm
going to have to
call Fibonacci twice.
In each case--
well, in one case at least, I'm
going to have to know what
to do to come back and
do the next one.
I have to remember, have I done
the first Fib, or have I
done the second one?
Do I have to come back to the
place where I do the second
Fib, or do I have to come
back to the place
where I do the add?
In the first case, over the
first Fibonacci, I'm going to
need the value of N for
computing for the second one.
So I have to store some
of these things up.
So first I'm going
to save continue.
That's who needs the answer.
And the reason I'm doing that is
because I'm about to assign
continue to the place
which is the place I
want to go to after.
Let's call it Fib-N-minus-1,
big long name,
classic Lisp name.
Because I'm going to compute
the first Fib of N minus 1,
and then after that, I
want to come back and
do something else.
That's the place I want to go
to after I've done the first
Fibonacci calculation.
And I want to do a save of N,
because I'm going to need it
later, after that.
Now I'm going to, at this point,
get ready to do the
Fibonacci of N minus 1.
So assign to N the difference
of the fetch of N and 1.
Now I'm ready to go back
to doing the Fib loop.
Have I satisfied my contract?
And the answer is yes.
N contains N minus 1, which
is what I need.
Continue contains a place I want
to go to when I'm done
with calculating N minus 1.
So I've satisfied
the contract.
And therefore, I can write
down here a label,
after-Fib-N-minus-1.
Now what am I going
to do here?
Here's a place where I now
have to get ready to do
Fib of N minus 2.
But in order to do a Fib of N
minus 2, look, I don't know.
I've clobbered my N over here.
And presumably my N is counted
down all the way to 1 or 0 or
something at this point.
So I don't know what the value
of N in the N register is.
I want the value of N that was
on the stack that I saved over
here so that could restore
it over here.
I saved up the value of N, which
is this value of N at
this point, so that I could
restore it after computing Fib
of N minus 1, so that I could
count that down to N minus 2
and then compute Fib
of N minus 2.
So let's restore that.
Restore of N.
Now I'm about to do something
which is superstitious, and we
will remove it shortly.
I am about to finish the
sequence of doing the
subroutine call, if you will.
I'm going to say, well, I also
saved up the continuation,
since I'm going to
restore it now.
But actually, I don't have
to, because I'm not
going to need it.
We'll fix that in a second.
So we'll do a restore of
continue, which is what I
would in general need to do.
And we're just going to see
what you would call in the
compiler world a peephole
optimization, which says,
whoops, you didn't
have to do that.
OK, so the next thing I see
here is that I have to get
ready now to do Fibonacci
of N minus 2.
But I don't have to
save N anymore.
The reason why I don't have to
save N anymore is because I
don't need N after I've done Fib
of N minus 2, because the
next thing I do is add.
So I'm just going to set
up my N that way.
Assign N minus difference
of fetch N and 2.
Now I have to finish the
setup for calling
Fibonacci of N minus 2.
Well, I have to save up continue
and assign continue,
continue, to the place which is
after Fib N 2, that place
over here somewhere.
However, I've got to
be very careful.
The old value, the value of Fib
of N minus 1, I'm going to
need later.
The value of Fibonacci of N
minus 1, I'm going to need.
And I can't clobber it, because
I'm going to have to
add it to the value of
Fib of N minus 2.
That's in the value register,
so I'm going to save it.
So I have to save this right
now, save up VAL.
And now I can go off to my
subroutine, go to Fib loop.
Now before I go any further
and finish this program, I
just want to look at this
segment so far and see, oh
yes, there's a sequence of
instructions here, if you
will, that I can do
something about.
Here I have a restore of
continue, a save of continue,
and then an assign of continue,
with no other
references to continue
in between.
The restore followed
by the save
leaves the stack unchanged.
The only difference is that I
set the continue register to a
value, which is the value
that was on the stack.
Since I now clobber that value,
as in it was never
referenced, these instructions
are unnecessary.
So we will remove these.
But I couldn't have seen
that unless I had
written them down.
Was that really true?
Well, I don't know.
OK, so we've now gone
off to compute
Fibonacci of N minus 2.
So after that, what are
we going to do?
Well, I suppose the first
thing we have to do--
we've got two things.
We've got a thing in
the value register
which is now valuable.
We also have a thing on the
stack that can be restored
into the value register.
And what I have to be careful
with now is I want to shuffle
this right so I can
do the multiply.
Now there are various
conventions I might use, but
I'm going to be very picky and
say, I'm only going to restore
into a register I've
saved from.
If that's the case, I have
to do a shuffle here.
It's the same problem with how
many hands I have. So I'm
going to assign to N, because
I'm not going to need N
anymore, N is useless, the
current value of VAL, which
was the value of Fib
of N minus 2.
And I'm going to restore
the value register now.
This restore matches this
save. And if you're very
careful and examine very
carefully what goes on,
restores and saves are
always matched.
Now there's an outstanding save,
of course, that we have
to get rid of soon.
And so I restored the
value register.
Now I restore the continue one,
which matches this one,
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot,
dot, down to here, restoring
that continuation.
That continuation is a
continuation of Fib of N,
which is the problem I was
trying to solve, a major
problem I'm trying to solve.
So that's the guy I have to go
back to who wants Fib of N. I
saved them all the way up here
when I realized N was
not less than 2.
And so I had to do a complicated
operation.
Now I've got everything
I need to do it.
So I'm going to restore that,
assign to VAL the sum of fetch
VAL and fetch of N, and
go to continue.
So now I've returned from
computing Fibonacci of N, the
general case.
Now what's left is we have to
fix up a few details, like
there's the base case of this
induction, immediate answer,
which is nothing more than
assign to VAL fetch of N,
because N was less than 2, and
therefore, the answer is N in
our original program, and
return continue--
bobble, bobble almost--
and finally Fib done.
So that's a fairly complicated
program.
And the reason I wanted you see
to that is because I want
you to see the particular
flavors of stack discipline
that I was obeying.
It was first of all, I don't
want to take anything that I'm
not going to need later.
I was being very careful.
And it's very important.
And there are all sorts of other
disciplines people make
with frames and things like that
of some sort, where you
save all sorts of junk you're
not going to need later and
restore it because, in some
sense, it's easier to do that.
That's going to lead to various
disasters, which we'll
see a little later.
It's crucial to say exactly
what you're
going to need later.
It's an important idea.
And the responsibility of that
is whoever saves something is
the guy who restores it,
because he needs it.
And in such discipline, you
can see what things are
unnecessary, operations
that are unimportant.
Now, one other thing I want to
tell you about that's very
simple is that, of course, the
picture you see is not the
whole picture.
Supposing I had systems that
had things like other
operations, CAR, CDR, cons,
building a vector and
referencing the nth element of
it, or things like that.
Well, at this level of detail,
whatever it is, we can
conceptualize those
as primitive
operations in the datapath.
In other words, we could say
that some machine that, for
example, has the append machine,
which has to do cons
of the CAR of x with the append
of the CDR of x and y,
well, gee, that's exactly
the same as
the factorial structure.
Well, it's got about
the same structure.
And what do we have?
We have some sort of things in
it which may be registers, x
and y, and then x has to somehow
move to y sometimes, x
has to get the value of y.
And then we may have
to be able to do
something which is a cons.
I don't remember if I need to
like this is in this system,
but cons is sort of like
subtract or add or something.
It combines two things,
producing a thing which is the
cons, which we may then
think goes into there.
And then maybe a thing called
the CAR, which will produce--
I can get the CAR
or something.
And maybe I can get the CDR
of something, and so on.
But we shouldn't be too afraid
of saying things this way,
because the worst that could
happen is if we open up cons,
what we're going to find
is some machine.
And cons may in fact overlap
with CAR and CDR, and it
always does, in the same way
that plus and minus overlap,
and really the same business.
Cons, CAR, and CDR are going to
overlap, and we're going to
find a little controller, a
little datapath, which may
have some registers in it,
some stuff like that.
And maybe inside it, there may
also be an infinite part, a
part that's semi-infinite or
something, which is a lot of
very uniform stuff, which
we'll call memory.
And I wouldn't be so horrified
if that were the way it works.
In fact, it does, and we'll
talk about that later.
So are there any questions?
Gee, what an unquestioning
audience.
Suppose I tell you a horrible
pile of lies.
OK.
Well, thank you.
Let's take our break.
[MUSIC PLAYING - "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY JOHANN
SEBASTIAN BACH]